a low carbohydrate diet is bad for you
in general unless it's a plant-based low
carbohydrate low carbohydrate diet and
high protein are not good for you it
should be the other way around low
protein High carbohydrate it's better
for lifespan to be an 80 carbohydrate
diet than to be in a low carbohydrate in
the longevity diet we talk about fats
yes but certain type of fats you know
the high olive oil high high diet is
better prominent experts who say go to a
no-fat diet no matter what it is sure it
seems to be true better to not have
saturated fats animal fats and again the
epidemiology agrees with that but when
we're talking about this monounsaturated
fats olive oil nuts probably certain
fish like salmon that seems to be
consistently associated with living
longer if a low carbohydrate diet it's
not so good for you let's look around